as usual I'm try to take us on a bit of
a journey through all the different
kinds of equations we've met before ok
so again don't just give me the final
number don't just give me the final
value can someone tell me a step 4 well
for this question the first one it is
only one step before all of them I think
out of your hair was up first ok great
take away 6 take away 6 that'll give me
k equals 7 fantastic ok so that's
probably the only one where you can
really just write one line ok we
subtracted seven both sides great
someone else give me a hand out for
number two yeah first that work I am
going to take away number five is
probably not the greatest choice my
question too I'm gonna I'm gonna take
away three I think that would be a
better choice because it will get the
pro to rule by itself on that side so
i'm going to write for p equals so i
took away three what does that leave me
with on the right-hand side yeah Rachel
minus now be careful this is a negative
number right so when I take away from it
it gets even more negative right so it's
a bigger than you know so we minus 26
okay now I'll just wait for ever's
attention because some of you guys would
be exceptionally rude by my bonus and
honestly like I did prepare this but we
don't have to play it like there's no
reason we have to it's not been forcing
us so I just wait for everyone to be
ready that's better thank you ok now we
have a look at this what's our next step
ok so where did to me from just to
confirm I've got minus 23 at the right
hand side right but then the thing I to
hear is tracted 3 from both sides there
was a step I didn't write down which was
if you do that to the right hand side
you're doing it tracted three right now-
hence that ok minus-20 would be a common
answer right because it looks like oh it
gets smaller but because negative it
actually gets more
negative okay next step I should divide
both sides by 4 now when you do that 26
doesn't go evenly into Ford's it's not a
multiple of 4 so what would you do for
this next step yeah jointly yeah okay so
you've gone straight to the decimal your
calculator will tell you that
alternatively i will write that down in
a second alternatively i could have just
worked with this over a simpler
equivalent fraction right what would I
cancel from the top bottom yeah I'll
take a two out of here which leaves me
with 13 and then I take it two out of
here which leave me with 2 so minus 13 /
2 that'll be fine or by this 6.5 or
minus six and a half they're all the
same at all ok good let's move on to
three you've got X's on both sides so
what are you going to do first yeah okay
I'm going to take this X away so that I
have all the x's in one spot that leaves
me with 2x plus 4 equals 6 okay now that
I've got the x's in one spot what would
be my next logical step yeah then you
okay get all the numbers also in one
spot so i get 2x and that leaves me with
the two last step someone else's sawdust
anything yeah Morgan division fantastic
which gives me one okay right last one
you've got some brackets remember you
had a choice of what you could do where
you've got brackets one of two things
what do you think is the best option
here yeah Daniel okay I could simplify
this what's the name of the particular
kind of simplifying I do when it's with
brackets they know expand it very good
okay so I'm good expand them and I'm
trying to help me out and expand it a
sign fantastic ok as we write that down
just want to draw everyone's attention
that's perfect to that minus 3 and the
plus 18 right a really common error is
to say oh cool i'll multiply by 3 we
just do it to the first one and we
forget to do one as well I'm here a lot
of pic 2 up I'm right just sort of like
get rid of the brackets but the two does
x the niners
which came from okay now that we're in
this I think we can sort of see what we
need to do right you got to our over
here right so i'm going to subtract it
from both sides which leaves me with how
be ours on this you decided to get
really familiar with this now I'm not
only going to subtract two are from both
sides I'm also get bored ID please me
with plus 3 21 that's it okay so you can
see walk to ball add quicker with these
you can start to do more than one step
at a time because we're doing much the
same thing okay